the guys that get laid and interviewing
the men that have been screwed by
divorce has made me had a completely
different point of view of women because
what I found out was that the guys that
get screwed over in divorce tend to be
the simp category where they think women
are these awesome Angels they're just
they could never do no wrong all you
have to do is find a good woman and
treat her well and you'll have a good
life and those are the ones that I I
just saw getting screwed over and
divorced it wasn't the rich guys um it
wasn't the cells it was the guy the
traditional men that wanted to get
married semi young usually in their 20s
and have a good life